I love that you're on Portlandia I look
here on Portlandia you play the mayor
that's fun
last season last season I was really
impressed because I saw the scene first
and then I found out afterwards that
last see that they had told you you're
the mayor
sing a song talking about how much you
left Portland as the mayor and we'll
play music and you just go no lyrics
just make it up as you go and so you
it was very impressive you just go with
it and sing a whole song about Portland
but you said that you channeled yeah a
great actor to help you through this
moment I did so you got I was grasping
at straws and I said well just and it's
William Shatner came into my mind and
I've got I said I've got a channel
Shatner how do you do that so that sort
of gave me such sort of starting off
point because you know Bill is Spock
bones I so that was nipping off point
yeah and so you channeled him and also
he's made quite a career out of singing
yes and and so you could channel him in
that way too
yes have you worked with shows before
yes I did a simply Shakespeare event
with Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson a couple
days ago and we did The Tempest this is
one where you get the script at noon and
you do a performance that evening right
so you just kind of want you know you
step through and sitting next to me was
Bill Shatner and I was completely in awe
I was totally starstruck he's one of
those guys like you know on your bucket
list of people you want to meet so we
had this great tour rapport and I'm
great on did you oh I did I did I told
him a story and and he and he and I said
listen if I can never return the favor
you know please feel free to channel me
if there's anything yeah I think I won't
yeah 25 years between Twin Peaks no
seasons now what does that mean if I'm
thinking knowing you guys you're slated
25 years from now yeah to pick up a
story again yeah
Cooper will have a walker he'll be
taking his coffee intravenous exactly
here
to wheel me out into bed yeah I'll solve
the case from there
yeah like Columbo come back Gibbs guard
yes
you